right if we go back to like the falling
out of the tree analogy people like that
are the type of kids who climb up the
tree fall break their arm and they go
what if I break another one
how many can I do yeah it's like weird
jobs you're like how did you get this
like you know like deep sea like cable
fixing people oh yeah like they [ __ ]
they I think you have to like they
depressurize yeah like a few weeks but
you're like on the floor of the ocean
fixing these cables it's like Twilight
Twilight simmers or swimmers or
something something insane there's a
really good documentary on Netflix about
a bunch of people in Scotland how
because they're attached to like an
umbilical cord yeah
um and I think one of one of the um one
of the dudes that Court got stuck oh
[ __ ] while they were because the weather
was was crazy up top yeah throwing the
boat around pulling this guy around the
floor bed yeah and it's it's crazy it's
it's like it's such anxiety yeah and
it's just like this job seems like one
why why would you decide to do this like
I'm sure the pay is insane yeah but like
my God to go to the ocean floor and just
fix oil companies pipes hell no the the
thing is the thing that's awful about
that is that you spend months just down
there oh yeah because because it because
it takes so long to depressurize it's
it's only financially viable if these
divers are just down there for months on
end for shifts right so you're just
living in a small [ __ ] pressurized
cave for months only to go out to
[ __ ] fix cables at the bottom of the
[ __ ] ocean I'm like that sounds like
the most awful job I can imagine we
respect all of you like huge [ __ ]
respect to anyone who does that you guys
are crazy it's like it's like that video
of the the guy who I think he works at
like a sewage like facility and he has
to like go into the sewage pools to like
fix uh like draining issues and [ __ ]
like that it's literally just a dude who
dives into [ __ ] for a living probably
just can't smell it probably not he's
just like cuts off his nose it's like
it's like jobs where you like where you
get exposed to certain things you become
like chefs who get oil burns on their
hands so much that they don't have any
feeling left in their fingers yeah right
right and it's you know there's I think
there's a few other ones with like smell
where you just get used to it you just
very quickly have to get it the oil ones
make sense because it's kind of like you
know when you first pick up a Guitar you
get like calluses
eventually either your skin hardens you
know or it's like multi right that like
have to deal with dead bodies and just
deal with this you just have to deal
with people we're [ __ ] good at
adapting yeah not me other people I I
think I'm good at sitting here and
talking well I I think you shouldn't
underestimate how adaptable humans are
oh no we are yeah just to get used to
something that you shouldn't get used to
oh God yeah I mean like look at how hot
is that how do you get used to that yeah
because I remember I saw like a a video
about like uh this you know just this
mortician who just like goes through his
day and just like describes his job and
[ __ ] like that the one on um [ __ ] was
his name wired oh there was that one as
well everyone [ __ ] loves that yeah
that one's that guy's awesome there's a
different guy as well yeah yeah there's
a different guy and he's just like goes
through like daily you know occurrences
of a mortician and it's just like yeah
so uh today I'm dealing with the two
patients he calls them patience I'm
dealing with two patients
um that died recently and uh yeah
they're basically just doctors oh wait
how is it like title doctor or something
yeah I think so I don't know well it's
kind of like a cross between it's like a
cross between a doctor and a makeup
artist right because it's like you have
to fix the body up obviously yeah but
they also have to make the body
presentable for a funeral or a coffin
it's just like yeah it's just like
really cool because like when you think
of like mortician you immediately think
of like a certain type of person right
but then you're immediately are just
like oh goth kid yeah the goth kids from
South Park right it's like but it's like
why would you want a job where you deal
with dead bodies every day but then when
you actually like look into it you're
just like oh these people are just like
every other person yeah I saw one where
it was um that one the white dude who
mentioned something along the lines of
it just makes you appreciate life a lot
more yeah because you're working with
dead bodies and seeing grieving families
a lot yeah you're really doing your best
to give grieving families a really like
appropriate goodbye yeah yeah and in
that sense I can understand why you
would see it as like okay I like doing
this job because I like giving families
the opportunity yeah to have the kind of
send off they want and giving them that
kind of closure morticians are just
doctors with no risk exactly I get to
close the loop you can't kill your
patient if he's already dead
[Laughter]
yeah I guess yeah I mean I wonder if
there's people in the freezer are
actually alive and they accidentally
finished them off by cutting them open
or something who knows who knows that's
a horror movie you know I'm pretty sure
that is a horror yeah there is I pretty
sure the horror movie is like that where
there's someone who's like frozen in the
morgue thing yeah they're alive and
someone's gonna open them up probably
some kind of urban legend no yeah
because I saw I saw this tick tocker as
well who his job was like a cleaner but
his specialty was like cleaning up crime
scenesis
yeah yeah and I'm just like there's just
the way he just talks about cleaning up
bits of brains so casually and I'm like
man [ __ ] Samuel Jackson didn't
keep his call in Pulp Fiction how how
are you how are you so chill how are you
so chill about it man it's I'm like I'm
a mushroom cloud making [ __ ]
[ __ ] there's there's a job that
I'm like is this okay for you to talk
about this in your fancy film so this
isn't film anything on the job but yeah
he recreates it I'm like is this this is
okay right like this is fine I think
it's fine it's just showing you it's
like people who film that talks in there
like McDonald's shift I'm like yeah like
I like [ __ ] McDonald's they're not
paying you enough yeah but like are you
a lab are you allowed to do this yeah
sometimes the manager is in like the
videos I'm like yeah it's just why my my
order of 60 nuggets is taking 20 minutes
because Outback I'm just hearing like
that's why the ice cream yeah it's
always [ __ ] broke yeah because the
[ __ ] because the [ __ ] technician
is telling tip talks about why he's
fixed his ice cream machines I've always
wondered about that because I remember
like there was this ice cream tick
tocker who like worked at like one of oh
that dude dude I know isn't it isn't it
stupid that I know exactly who you're
talking about from all these jobs yeah
there's like the guy yeah there was the
guy the guy who makes the ice cream on
the table yeah on the table it's like
it's like POV I think it makes different
kind of ice cream like the Cold Stone
Creamery yeah the Cold Stone Creamery
guy yeah yeah is that what he's called
well no no name of the store and then
there's the guy who does the subway oh
yeah yeah and it's literally him but
just a reskin
it's crazy right
yeah and I'm just like which subway is
this being filmed at like what are you
what do you think owns the subway oh he
owns his family owns the shop oh okay so
that's like big pranks it's like you're
double dipping in revenue streams yeah I
respect it but if you're just straight
up like an employee yeah you've got the
GoPro on you're like so today I had this
customer that came in and it's
definitely hey hey hey hey we got an
order because sometimes you imagine
being the customer when he starts
monologuing yeah because he's like
watching like a Nile red video unfold
behind you you're like Nile not Nile not
not now it's not sulfuric acid chocolate
chip not now
I don't know it makes you weirdly
uncomfortable in a weird way yeah
because sometimes you see the customers
in there and I'm just like it's I would
be like stop [ __ ] tick-tocking myself
I don't give a [ __ ] I want a goddamn
sandwich yeah like what can you make my
okay can you imagine can you imagine
these Tick Tock as existing in Japan
like like a customer comes in in the
Subway or something in Japan and you're
like excuse me may I film a tick tock
while I'm making your Subway I wonder if
they ask I I kind of like it though like
I like the idea that I do this I'm like
can I have a can I have a chicken nugget
and uh so I mean this customer came in
and asked you for and I'm like yeah
because because I'm standing right here
yeah
it is just in a funny world but the
thing is right the thing is you can
clearly see in these tick tocks they're
using both hands so the customer comes
in and then there must be this guy with
a [ __ ] ring with his like phone in
front of his face and just like yes
because someone's like taped to his face
he's like yes can I take your order by
the way I'm gonna be filming a tick tock
of your order if that's okay I would
like it there I think it'd be sick I'd
love to go to a fast food place and
they're doing it I don't know why I
think it's awesome like it's it's like I
hope that they have all the permissions
to do it so they don't get [ __ ] for it
and don't lose their job but yeah I
think it's awesome I love this trend of
I'm gonna film me doing my job like I
feel like every single job is
interesting it just it's just about
presenting it as interesting oh yeah
yeah exactly like there's that doo-doo
fixes carpets just replaces carpets have
you seen that guy no dude just like I'm
not even remotely interested in any of
this but sometimes I'll just watch yeah
my favorite thing about Tick Tock or
this kind of [ __ ] they do is when they
they add something they do something in
the short or The Tick Tock that is just
immediately the only thing anyone can
focus on and it's has nothing to do with
your subject
so in this one carpet fixing thing for
some reason he shows b-roll of his fish
and it's a tiny tiny Fishbowl like the
ones you would get at like the dollar
store yeah and it's a fish in it and
just all the comments are like bruh for
real you showing us the fish that's
being like that's in like uh a David
Blaine skit like like all the comments
are just about this thing nobody is
talking about him fixing this carpet and
there's a bunch of other tick tocks
right I can't think of it it's off my
head but you'll watch a video and maybe
they'll have like a really big hand or
something yeah and all the comments will
be like is nobody gonna talk about their
hand yeah like I remember this one where
this dude shirt is like a wedding ring
yeah in briefly in a shop and it was on
so goddamn tight who's doing something
else and all the comments were like this
bro about an amputate his finger and it
was just literally all that I love that
that's yeah that's my favorite part of
that and comments enhance the the
funniness of it yeah well the thing is
like I think there's a whole sub-genre
of that on Tick Tock where it's just
like people doing things narrating about
something that's nothing to do with the
thing that they're doing oh yeah you
know and I think like ironically a time
lapse yeah yeah ironically I think what
started how this trend started was
probably like in the drama Community
because like remember like the good old
leafy days where it would just be good
old yeah the the the good old leafy days
where he would just be using like some
clips of Cs go surfing yeah and then
just talking about dramas like some [ __ ]
and I'm like why is the Cs go surfing
here what's that got to do with the
point of the video people but not people
still do that people still do that right
all they've done is just replace the CSO
go the Cs go surfing yeah and then
they've replaced the drama with just
anything now yeah my favorite trend is
the uh it's like the girls going if you
had like two minutes with me what would
you do and it's just something
completely unrelated I [ __ ] love this
have you seen them with the Geo guesser
dude oh yeah yeah if you had five
minutes with me what would it be the
same goal right here and then we're
going to Thailand right now
I just I just cracks me up the ones that
are like tell me you did this thing
without telling me you did this thing
and he's like no anyway so we're here in
Sweden right now
I love this looks like Ecuador all right
got it
I just yeah I think there's generally
some really funny tick tocks there
there's just so much crap oh my god dude
um [ __ ] I don't even know if I should
mention it so I I um
found this Tick Tock and
um
I won't give too many details because I
don't want to give it away and I don't
want to give them [ __ ]
um so I was you know I was none of my
own business one of my friends School
messages me yeah and he's like bruh look
at this I open the tick tock and it's
it's it's
like a tick tock where there's like a
giant age difference right between the
couple I think I know what you're
talking about and and I'm like oh that's
kind of gross it was like 70 and like
20. yeah okay I know I know exactly what
you're talking about and it was like
like hey you know me I like all the
women you know how it is right age
difference you know I don't mean [ __ ]
but there is a limit there is a limit to
how listen if you're putting the guy in
there into a retirement home at 23 you
got stuff to worry I mean come on
so you know we're kind of doing this and
I messaged back and I'm like wow that's
weird he's like wait didn't you realize
I like real wait realized one he's like
oh that's the that's the goal we went to
school with and I was like what he said
yeah that's the girl we went to school
with I'm like what I'm like oh [ __ ] it
is oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] and I'm like oh my
God and this Tick Tock has like millions
and millions of views right right I was
like what the [ __ ] this is so bizarre
this is like such a weird timeline yeah
I feel like I'm on I was like this is
weird because like yeah no I know
exactly how you feel because like it's
like when you discover that like this
one random person yeah yeah that's no
there's one random person who made this
like hyper popular meme where you don't
know where it came from yeah is like
someone who's not that far degree of
separation from you yeah yeah like I had
that recently actually like uh do you
know that one it's easy if I just show
you but like you know the one where it's
like the girl just being like Oh look a
dandelion must be the last one of the
Season then eats the dandelion no no
okay so it's basically this like Ice Age
one and it's like really funny and like
it made its rounds all the way back to
the Ice Age binge I mean baby it came up
on my thing and I'm just like that's
hilarious because she just like eats
this dandelion just like spits it out
and so I I and so my sister and I share
memes a lot yeah and so I sent this one
because I'm like you appreciate it I say
it's just as much as me so I sent it to
her and she's like bro I went to school
with her I'm serious just like like she
was like my best friend in high school
I'm just like
the [ __ ] and you never told me about
this you never told me that your friend
from high school made one of the
funniest Ice Age memes on Tick Tock like
what the [ __ ] and it was so hit me up we
can be best friends mom yeah I want some
of that cloud yeah it's weird being a
person who does stuff online and then
like you feel that like you're like the
only one in your friend group yeah right
yeah you know and you're like oh my god
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah I mean like
remember back in the day where it's like
they said everyone will get their 15
minutes of fame or something I think
that's like coming becoming more true no
that's 15 seconds of Fame man that was
15 seconds of Fame now for fame right
because everyone like most of most my
mates they have like one claim of
something that's happened online whether
it'd be like oh I had a had a post blow
up on Reddit and get the front page or
some [ __ ] you know there's always like
something I think that has happened
where something you've done online has
just blown up out of your control for
good reasons hopefully for good reason
I'm on the front page Why is it nice
guys what
do you mean